[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: Today we're going to
discuss bioenergetics, continue
that discussion and use
that as a transition
into also beginning to see how
that applies to understanding
glycolysis, the pathway that
allows glucose breakdown.
So just as a reminder of
a couple of the points
that we discussed last
time, so last time
we discussed what makes
reactions favorable.
And so remember, you could
have any reaction, A to B--
A to B could be a single step.
A to B could be an
entire pathway, all steps
in the pathway, that
whether or not that reaction
or pathway happens is
determined by thermodynamics.
It's not determined by enzymes.
Enzymes are
important, of course,
to control the rate
of reactions so they
may allow things to happen
that otherwise wouldn't happen.
But whether the
reaction happens or not
is determined by free energy.
And so free energy,
delta G, remember
we discussed is the
following relationship.
So it's related to
this constant delta G0
prime, which is related
to the equilibrium
constant for any pair of
products and reactants
as well as this formula rt
times the log of the products
over the reactants.
And so remember this means
that whether a reaction happens
depends on the
equilibrium constant,
but it also depends on the
actual conditions present.
That is how much substrate
and how much product is there.
And so what this means is that
biology can come up with ways
by keeping the product
concentrations low to do things
that may move in the opposite
direction of what you would
predict from equilibrium.
And also by coupling these
less favorable reactions
to more favorable reactions,
you can also allow biology
to do unfavorable stuff.
And this is, of course, where
the role of ATP comes in.
And we discussed this at the
end of last time as well.
Of course, what's important
then becomes the ratio of ATP
to ADP.
And to illustrate that,
we use this example.
We use the-- remember ATP
hydrolysis has a delta G0 prime
of minus 7.5 kcals per mole.
That, of course,
tells you this is
about the equilibrium constant.
That tells us the equilibrium
lies to the right.
We can couple it to this
first reaction in glycolysis,
which traps glucose in the cell
by adding a phosphate group.
Delta G0 prime for this is
positive 3.3 kcals per mole.
This positive number tells
you that the equilibrium
lies towards the left.
But when we couple these
two reactions together,
we add these two
numbers together,
and now we get a delta G0 prime
of minus 4.2 kcals per mole,
which are the coupled reaction.
The equilibrium lies
now again to the right.
And that's how we can use
ATP hydrolysis in order
to carry out this
unfavorable process, trapping
the glucose in the cell.
Now how much glucose
will be trapped?
Well, of course, that will come
from this reaction up here.
And that's because
whether or not
a reaction occurs
or not of course
depends not on the
equilibrium constant
but on the actual conditions and
the delta G of that reaction.
And so we can just plug
that in for this system.
And so we see delta G0 prime
minus 4.2 kcals per mole.
That says equilibrium
lies to the right.
But how far really
depends on the conditions.
And that's defined by this ratio
of products over reactants.
And you can imagine that
this term here, as long
as it's less than 4.2, you
will favor glucose trapping
inside the cell,
whereas, of course,
if it's greater than
4.2, then you'd favor--
the opposite direction
would be favorable.
Now this is really critical
because this really
explains how it is
that ATP actually
works to help cells
do various reactions.
And so if an ATP-ADP
ratio exists such
that it can make
delta G less than 0
for the reaction
that it's coupled to,
that is how it provides
the energy that then allows
unfavorable reactions to occur.
And so please do not
make the common mistake
that many, many biologists
make when they state,
oh, ATP equals energy.
There's a lot of ATP.
The cell must have
a lot of energy.
Remember it's the
ratio of ATP to ADP
that provides the energy.
And so that means
ATP can be sky high,
but if ADP is equally high,
there's no energy there.
Consequently, ATP
can be very low.
But if ADP is extremely
low, now you still
have a high ATP to ADP ratio.
And that is what
provides the energy.
And that's because this occurs
regardless of concentration.
It's because it's this
ratio of ATP to ADP
that ultimately says how much
energy is there for the ATP
to drive a reaction.
In other words, delta G,
or whatever the reaction
is coupled to, is going
to be proportional
to the ratio of ADP to ATP.
Great.
Now how much ATP
do you need then?
What ratio do you need
to drive a reaction?
Well, it's hard to say
that in absolute terms
because it's going to be defined
by how that ratio is coupled
to the ratio of whatever
other reactants and products.
It also tells you, remember,
as we talked about before, we
can switch the directions
of these reactions
and we just flip the signs.
The directions
here are arbitrary.
And so that means
it also tells us
how much energy we need
to put in if we're going
to charge up an ATP-ADP ratio.
In other words, if
we want to synthesize
ATP, that is take
ADP plus phosphate
and make an ATP,
well, what's this?
What we just-- the
exact opposite sign
of that delta G0 prime
is going to now equal
plus 7.5 kcals per mole.
And so that means that the
equilibrium of this reaction
is going to lie to the left just
as that one lied to the right.
And it's going to lie to
the left by that much.
And if we want to know
how much energy it then
takes to make ATP,
well, obviously, it's
not going to happen
because equilibrium
favors this direction.
It's not spontaneous
in that direction.
But at various
conditions, we can
know by plugging in our
formula delta G equals delta
G0 prime plus 7.5 kcals per mole
plus RT times the log of ATP.
So if I have my ADP--
I'm sorry-- my ATP concentration
sufficiently low relative
to my ADP concentration,
I can still
make this reaction happen.
Now that's not going to give
you an ATP-ADP ratio that
is actually consistent with
being able to do anything
else into the cell.
And so but what it says is that
if I am able to couple energy
from nutrient metabolism
to this reaction
and overcome this positive
7.5 kcals per mole,
that basically will allow me to
now synthesize ATP and maintain
an ATP-ADP ratio in the cell
that allows cells to carry out
other functions
by the same rules
that we talked about that
would be unfavorable.
Now there's lots of implications
here for metabolism,
because it says how much input
you need to synthesize ATP.
How much energy you
need to synthesize ATP
is going to depend on how
charged this ratio is.
And how useful that ratio is
to catalyze other reactions
is also going to depend on
how charged that ratio is.
And in essence, this is why
we cannot store energy as ATP.
This is why we didn't
eat ATP for breakfast
and instead ate cereal that
has a bunch of glucose in it,
because we can use that glucose
to get ATP but the ATP itself
is not something that we
really can burn to get energy
in a sustained way.
In other words, the
delta G of ATP synthesis,
making ATP is going
to be proportional
to the log of the ratio of ATP
over ADP for all the reasons
I described.
The delta G of using
ATP, ATP hydrolysis,
using ATP to drive
reactions is also
proportional to RT times the
log, in this case, of the ADP
to ATP ratio.
And so because you need to
consume this ratio to get
energy, and you need to put in
energy to create this ratio,
you are constant-- and how much
is an exponential property--
you are constantly
having to generate
ATP in a way that
allows you to then
have a ratio that
can then be consumed
to fuel other reactions.
And that's what's shown
here on the slide.
So I just graphed here
what the ATP-ADP ratio
is relative to a
theoretical delta
G that's shown here as a linear
scale, here on a log scale,
that basically there's this
logarithmic relationship
and so you need an exponential
increase in energy input
to drive this ratio up higher
in order to, quote unquote,
"store" more energy that
can be used for later.
And so this system is not one
that you can use as an energy
storage system and
ultimately explains
why cells have to do
constant metabolism,
have to constantly do
some sort of metabolism
to keep this ATP-ADP
ratio charged
for it to be in a useful range
to have an ATP-ADP ratio that
can be coupled to
drive otherwise
unfavorable reactions
in our cells.
So to say this
another way, our cells
need to constantly catabolize
nutrients, burn glucose,
burn some other fuel.
They have to do
this because they
have to keep that ratio
charged in a range
where that can then support
other cell functions,
allow them to fight entropy
and maintain order in biology.
We alluded last time if
you stop making ATP, well,
what's going to happen?
Well, that ATP-ADP
ratio the cell
has is going to fuel
whatever reactions it
can do until suddenly that ratio
falls below the point where
it's useful to drive those
unfavorable reactions.
In fact, if you
stop ATP production,
you will consume that
ATP-ADP ratio in seconds.
And this is why if you
poison ATP production,
cells die very quickly.
Remember last time we mentioned
you have a heart attack,
blood flow stops
going to a tissue.
No more nutrients and
oxygen. Cells die quickly.
Cyanide poisoning
does the same thing.
Cells die quickly if
you stop their ability
to maintain this ATP-ADP
ratio in the right range.
And so remember
the concentration,
the absolute concentration
of ATP for these reasons
is not a good indicator
of cell energy.
The correct indicator
of cell energy
is the ratio of ATP to ADP.
This term is sometimes referred
to as the energy charge.
And so that can be
the ATP to ADP ratio,
or oftentimes more correctly
is the ATP to AMP ratio.
Why the ATP to AMP ratio?
Well, that's because
once you understand this,
you can now understand that
cells have a failsafe mechanism
to protect themselves if
this ratio of ATP to ADP
becomes too low.
What is that mechanism?
Well, you can carry
out this reaction.
Take two ATP molecules
and turn them
into transfer a phosphate
to make an ATP plus an AMP.
Why is that a
failsafe mechanism?
Well, if they care about
this, if the ATP-ADP ratio is
what maintains your
ability to drive
these thermodynamically
unfavorable reactions,
if I sacrifice the
denominator by removing an ATP
and get an ATP out of it,
I've now at least temporarily
fixed that ratio.
Now this is something that
obviously cannot go on forever.
But in the short
term, it does allow
cells to protect that ratio.
And in fact, what cells actually
defend is this ATP-AMP ratio.
And it's very, very difficult
to change the ATP-AMP ratio
in a cell and
actually have it live.
So it's really
this ATP-AMP ratio
that is most formally
related to what
would be called energy charge.
But this is really why
this is important is
for all the reasons
that I just described.
All right.
So hopefully, it's
clear to you now
why cells have to keep ATP-ADP
ratio in the right range, why
this is useful for
them to now carry out
all of these unfavorable
reactions-- fight entropy,
stave off death.
And they can even have a
failsafe here and sacrifice ADP
as a way to try to maintain
that as a very last resort.
It also says why cells have
to always do catabolism,
because you always need
the energy input to keep
that ratio in the right range.
However, you might imagine
that, in real life,
the messiness of
biology, that there's
lots of situations
where the demand for ATP
will suddenly increase.
Well, of course, maybe you can
just metabolize more sugar,
do more nutrient catabolism to
try to keep that ratio high.
But that takes time.
And so you need ways for
cells to quickly respond
to then allow them to mobilize
all of this extra thing to--
extra fuel to do that.
For example, we're walking
around our ancestors
on the plains somewhere
and a lion appears.
We don't have time to
mobilize a bunch of new fuel.
We have to be able to
run away really quickly
or the lion's going to eat us.
And so cells have systems
to suddenly respond
to I need a lot more ATP demand
to run away by having ways
that one can buffer
this ATP-ADP ratio,
protect it in the short
term, and allow cells time
to ramp up nutrient metabolism
in order to keep this high.
All right.
Well, if we wanted to
create such a buffer system,
how would we actually do it?
Well, obviously,
we have to follow
all the rules of thermodynamics
that we discussed.
And we have to do
so in a way that
actually illustrates
how it is that
very well how metabolism works.
In other words, if
suddenly the ATP-ADP ratio
drops, if we have a sudden
drop in ATP-ADP ratio
because we have
increased demand,
needing to run away
from a lion, how
could we actually
create a buffer system
that protects this?
Well, to do it, we would
need to couple ATP-ADP
to some other product
reactant pair,
let's call them x and y,
such that the ratio of y to x
is coupled to the
ratio of ATP to ADP.
And you want it
coupled in such a way
that if that ratio goes down,
this ratio can now protect ATP,
basically favor ATP
to ADP synthesis.
However, when
nutrients are plentiful
and this ratio is really
high, it then in turn
can charge up this ratio so
that it can buffer it later
when the ATP-ADP
ratio starts to fall.
Now the most famous
example of this
actually comes from
muscle physiology.
And it's best described
in terms of muscles
and how they quickly
respond to increased demand,
like that running
away from a lion.
However, it in fact applies
to many, many cells,
including most non-muscle
cells in animals.
All right.
And I should say
that it turns out
that if you turn off ATP
synthesis in a muscle,
people have estimated that
your ATP-ADP ratio will fall
into a range where it is no
longer useful to do anything
within a matter of seconds, some
claim even less than a second.
And so this system ends
up being very important.
Now the system that muscle
uses, and many other cells
do as well, is something called
the creatine/creatine phosphate
system.
Now if you guys are
weightlifters or bodybuilders
out there, you probably
have heard of creatinine
because it's a very
popular supplement that
is taken for weightlifting,
something I obviously
don't do a lot of.
But that creatine/creatine
phosphate is out there.
I'll describe to you what it
actually does for muscle cells.
And you can decide for
yourself if this is actually
useful as a energy or
weightlifting supplement.
So what is
creatine/creatine phosphate?
What does it look like?
Well, it's basically
looks like this.
By the way, I will use
this abbreviation often
throughout this course,
just a shorthand
to draw a lot of
these structures.
So this here would be
a carboxylic acid group
drawn like this or like that,
drawn to the carboxylic acid
group just so you
understand my shorthand.
OK.
So this here is the
molecule creatine.
If I put a phosphate here, this
now becomes creatine phosphate.
Again, just to remind you,
this P with a circle over it
is a phosphate group.
I'll draw this particular
phosphate group
because it's a
nitrogen-phosphate bond,
a phosphoramidate bond.
This is actually a bond that is
more labile than the PO bonds
that we're used to seeing in
the phosphodiesters like ATP,
et cetera.
All right.
So that's creatine and
creatine phosphate.
And if we draw out the
reaction, creatine phosphate
goes to creatine plus inorganic
phosphate, so hydrolysis
of creatine phosphate.
This has a delta G0 prime
of minus 10 kcals per mole.
What does that mean?
It's negative.
Tells us about the
equilibrium constant.
Equilibrium lies to the right.
Remember ATP to ADP
hydrolysis shown over there,
that hydrolysis has
a delta G0 prime
of minus 7.5 kcals per mole.
Equilibrium also
lies to the right.
This number is more negative.
This equilibrium lies
further to the right
than ATP hydrolysis does.
So now what happens if
we couple this reaction
to the ATP hydrolysis reaction?
So now we can do ATP
plus creatine goes
to creatine phosphate plus ADP.
So we've coupled those
two reactions together.
So delta G0 prime, ATP
to ADP is minus 7.5.
Creatine phosphate
to creatine in
that direction is negative 10.
In this direction, it
would be positive 10.
And so as I've
drawn the reaction,
this delta G0 prime will
be plus 2.5 kcals per mole.
10 minus 7.5 plus 2.5,
which tells us then
that this equilibrium
now lies to the left.
However, which direction
this reaction actually goes
is not determined only
by the equilibrium.
It's really determined by delta
G. So we can calculate that.
So delta G equals
delta G0 prime plus RT
log of, as we've drawn
it, creatine phosphate
over creatine and ADP over ATP.
So you can now imagine
that this term here
is the sum of those two.
So it's plus 2.5.
And so if this term is less
than 2.5, what does that mean?
Well, if it's--
I'm sorry.
Less than negative 2.5, then
delta G will be negative
and you will favor creatine
phosphate production.
If this term is greater
than negative 2.5,
then delta G will
be positive and you
will favor ATP production.
Why is that important?
Well, if you think
about the conditions,
how you could make
this term less than 2.5
or less than negative 2.5 or
greater than negative 2.5,
basically, what's
going to happen
is that if the
ATP-ADP ratio is high,
lots of energy around,
no problems charging up,
lots of things to use, charge
up this ATP/ADP to a very
high ratio, well, now you
will favor this direction,
creatine phosphate synthesis.
However, if ATP/ADP begins
to fall and is lower,
well, now this term
is going to flip
and you'll now favor
ATP production.
And so basically, by charging
up this creatine/creatine
phosphate ratio, it
now creates a situation
where it can buffer that ATP/ADP
ratio so that when times are
good, you charge up the buffer.
When times are bad, you
then consume the buffer
in a way that allows you
to protect your ATP/ADP
ratio for a short time.
And this is illustrated
very nicely here
in this slide that
basically shows what
happens in muscle physiology.
And so this is just
a theoretical curve
that if you suddenly need
to contract your muscle
and you stop ATP production,
well, ATP levels will fall.
That ATP/ADP ratio more
correctly will fall rapidly
within the cell.
Creatine phosphate
will then now kick in
to protect that ATP/ADP
ratio as you can ramp up
either anaerobic or aerobic
metabolism to now buffer
that ATP/ADP ratio and keep
that muscle functioning.
Now I want to make one point
because oftentimes biochemistry
textbooks will refer
to things like ATP
or creatine phosphate
as, quote unquote,
"high energy compounds."
And of course, I guess
they are high energy
because they have these
labile phosphate-nitrogen
or phosphate-oxygen bonds.
And because they're labile,
hydrolysis is favorable.
And to a certain extent,
it's that hydrolysis
that is providing energy.
But remember it's
not the metabolite
or the bond in isolation that's
really providing the energy.
It's these ratios of ATP to ADP,
creatine phosphate to creatine,
that allow you to couple,
for all the reasons
we've spent now a lecture
and a half discussing,
two other reactions that really
provides biological energy.
All right.
Now we're ready
to discuss how it
is that we can use glucose
oxidation, nutrient catabolism,
to keep ATP/ADP high, that is
in a useful range, where it can
allow cells to do
otherwise thermodynamically
unfavorable things.
So how could we
make this happen?
Well, just like this example
with creatine and creatine
phosphate, if we want to
use nutrient catabolism
to do the same thing, we
need to couple reactions
of glucose oxidation,
nutrient catabolism, that
will allow us to
synthesize ATP, ADP to ATP,
and have that
synthesis be favorable
despite the high
ATP/ADP ratio in cells.
So let's think about it.
So what is this?
Nutrient catabolism.
What did we talk
about last time?
Oxidizing glucose
to carbon and CO2.
So here's our reaction for that.
So here's carbohydrate,
glucose CH2O6 plus six O2
goes to six CO2 plus six H2O.
That's the chemical
formula for burning wood.
So delta G0 prime for this
is minus 686 kcals per mole.
Quite a negative number.
Equilibrium greatly favors
the completely burned state,
oxidized state, of
that carbohydrate.
And so you can imagine
that this equilibrium is
so favorable to the right, if
we couple this reaction to ATP
synthesis, you're clearly going
to have plenty of energy there
in order to maintain
that ATP/ADP
ratio in the right range
to be compatible with cells
using it to do other things.
All right.
So how do we actually do that?
Well, if we do it,
we have to follow
the same rules of thermodynamics
and do the same things
that we did before.
Basically, we have to do
this reaction in a way
that we can draw out a
similar type of equation
as we did for creatine
and creatine phosphate.
And at the highest level, that
is how nutrient catabolism
will allow us to keep
ATP/ADP ratio high
even as ATP hydrolysis
is constantly
fueling all these other
unfavorable processes
in the cell.
Now if we did this all in one
step, our burning wood example,
lots of heat is generated.
That's too much energy.
Not so good for biology.
But rather what biology does,
as we alluded to last time,
is that because what we
talked about in the beginning,
that all of the things
that we discussed
are true for
individual reactions
or many, many reactions,
basically, if we turn A into B
and we do it in one
step, like burning wood,
or we do it in 500 steps, the
thermodynamic consequences
are exactly the same.
And so what we need to do is do
stepwise catabolism of glucose
and take advantage of the fact
that that delta G change is
the same whether it's
one step or many steps
and in that stepwise fashion
build in reactions where
we create intermediate
chemistries that allow us to do
things like we did with
creatine and creatine phosphate
such that we can favor ATP
synthesis when ATP/ADP ratio is
in the physiological range.
And in essence,
this is the magic
of how biology does this
and basically couples
nutrient catabolism in
order to provide energy.
And so the pathway that
we're going to discuss today
and in the next
lecture is something
called glycolysis, which
simply put is glucose lysis.
It's the stepwise
chemical oxidation
of glucose, which we know
from our burning wood
example is favorable.
And we're going to use this
pathway that basically will
be a pathway to allow the
stepwise lysis of glucose,
a favorable reaction, to
individual steps that set it up
in a way such that
ADP to ATP synthesis
is favored despite a
physiological ATP/ADP ratio.
Now I want to point out that
this really illustrates,
back to that high
energy compound thing,
that ATP is not the only
energy currency in the cell.
In fact, glucose is much more
energy for a cell than ATP.
You get much more energy
released from burning wood
than you get from
hydrolyzing ATP.
And in essence,
this is why we use
glucose-- why nature
has used glucose,
and other molecules like
it, as an energy storage
device, because here is a
relatively stable molecule,
can sit around for
a long time, and you
can burn it when you need it to
keep your ATP-ADP ratio high.
All right.
So, at the level of
reactions and pathways
now, how can we use glucose
oxidation and couple
it to drive ATP synthesis?
Well, hopefully it's
very clear that we
have to basically
set up a situation
like this
creatine-creatine-phosphate
system that we
already discussed.
And so I want to
start by discussing,
what are the reactions in
glycolysis that ultimately
behave like this and allow this
favorable ADP-to-ATP synthesis?
And then we will go
ahead and consider
how we can make
those reactions work
in the context of an
entire pathway that
allows glucose oxidation.
All right.
Now, like creatine,
phosphate, and creatine,
both of the steps
in glycolysis that
favor ATP synthesis
involve intermediates
where you have phosphate
on some molecule,
plus ADP goes to ATP
plus the phosphate
coming off that molecule.
Now, if we go to our
creatine-creatine-phosphate
system, obviously
this equilibrium
needs to lie to the right.
And so the first one
of these is as follows.
It involves this molecule,
phosphoenolpyruvate, also
referred to as PEP.
You will see
throughout the course
that we love to give
these little acronyms
to our metabolites because
it's hard to constantly
say and write out
phosphoenolpyruvate.
Much easier to say PEP.
So phosphoenolpyruvate
plus ADP goes to ATP.
Plus, if I take the
phosphate off of there,
I get this molecule.
This molecule is enolpyruvate.
Enolpyruvate can be
rearranged as follows.
To make this molecule
a ketone pyruvate.
You'll note-- hopefully remember
from your organic chemistry
classes that ketones
like pyruvate
can exist in two forms.
They can exist in the ketone
form or the enol form,
rearranging via the
chemistry that I've shown.
The keto form is greatly
favored over the enol form.
However, by having a phosphate
trap pyruvate the enol form--
phosphoenolpyruvate, when
you remove the phosphate
and it's wanting to
exist in the keto form,
greatly enhances the
energetics of this--
basically makes the
reaction, the equilibrium
want to lie very
far to the right.
And by the way of
chemical tricks like this
and others like it, you will see
used over and over in biology.
In fact, this is
illustrated, if we
asked what's delta G0
prime for this reaction,
it's minus 15 kcals per mole.
That tells us that the
equilibrium of this reaction
lies to the right.
In fact, it lies far to the
right, and in fact, this is--
you may remember ATP hydrolysis
is negative 7.5 kcals per mole.
So lies twice as far to the
right as ATP hydrolysis does.
And in fact, this minus 15 kcals
per mole is the most favorable,
at least in terms of
individual reactions
that at least I know
of in metabolism.
All right.
Well, if this equilibrium
for this is PEP to pyruvate,
this here is delta
G0 prime for ATP-ADP.
So if we want to
know what's delta G0
prime for the entire reaction,
well, if PEP to pyruvate
is minus 15, ATP to
ADP is minus 7.5.
Well here, we're going in
the opposite direction,
so it'd be plus 7.5.
So it's minus 15 plus 7.5, means
that for the entire reaction,
this is minus 7.5
kcals per mole.
Means that this is favorable,
equilibrium lies to the right.
If we drew out--
I'm not going to do it again
because I've done it a lot,
but if we redrew
out this equation,
replacing pyruvate and
PEP in the correct places,
there for creatine,
phosphate, and creatine,
you would see that there's
lots of conditions within cells
that will favor
ATP synthesis even
when ATP-ADP ratio is high.
All right.
This reaction is catalyzed by an
enzyme called pyruvate kinase.
And pyruvate kinase is a classic
example of a, quote-unquote,
"irreversible reaction."
However, I want to point
out that the enzyme pyruvate
kinase is actually named for
the reverse reaction that's
supposedly irreversible.
Pyruvate kinase.
If you take pyruvate and
you act on the kinase
as you learn from
Professor Yaffe,
that phosphorylates something.
You phosphorylate
pyruvate, you get
phosphoenolpyruvate
pyruvate kinase.
And so remember that absolutely
no reaction is reversible.
It's only reversed-- what they
mean by irreversible when they
say pyruvate kinase step in
glycolysis is irreversible,
is that it is
effectively irreversible
under the conditions that
are compatible with life
that exist in cells.
Of course, if you have very
low ADP and very high ATP,
you can come up with a
way to net synthesize PEP.
You just can't drive
the reverse reaction
under the ATP-ADP and the
PEP pyruvate ratios that
physiologically exist in cells.
However, this is
set up in a way such
that you can favor ADP-to-ATP
synthesis by converting
PEP to pyruvate in
a pathway, as we
will see happens in glycolysis.
All right.
Now, the second reaction
that I want to--
that allows ATP
synthesis in glycolysis
is catalyzed by an enzyme
called phosphoglycerate kinase.
And this carries out
the following reaction.
OK.
So this molecule is
1,3-Bisphosphoglycerate,
abbreviated 1,3-BPG.
And basically the phosphate
is transferred from here
to ADP, which gives you this
molecule, 3-phosphoglycerate
or 3-PG.
So this reaction,
the delta G0 prime
for the entire coupled reaction,
both steps of the reaction,
is minus 4.5 kcals per mole.
Tells you about the
equilibrium constant.
Equilibrium lies to the right,
doesn't lie as far to the right
as the PEP plus ADP goes to
ATP plus pyruvate reaction,
but nonetheless, is
one where there's
lots of conditions that are
favorable in cells to maintain
a high ATP-ADP ratio,
although we will see later
that this reaction actually
runs quite close to equilibrium
in cells, so there's
actually conditions
where it can go in the
opposite direction as well,
and we'll get to that
later in the course.
I want to point out one thing
about this, one thing that
makes this reaction
favorable, as you notice here
that this is a phosphate
on an acid group,
a so-called acid anhydride.
And this is a pretty
good phosphate donor.
And so you want to lose
that phosphate, which
is one of the reasons
why this reaction is
favorable for ATP synthesis
even at high ATP-ADP ratios.
All right.
So these are the two
reactions in glycolysis
that can favor ATP synthesis
at a high ATP-ADP ratio
just like creatine and
creatine phosphate.
And so hopefully now it's become
apparent to you that if during
our pathway of glucose
catabolism we can build
a pathway that couples what
we already know is favorable,
glucose oxidation, to
generate these intermediates,
PEP and 1,3-Bisphosphoglycerate,
lacerate we can then build
a pathway where those reactions
can make synthesis of ATP
favorable even though there's
a high ATP-ADP ratio in cells,
and in fact, maintain that
high ATP-ADP ratio in cells.
And in essence, this is
the logic or the goal,
if you will, of
glycolysis and why
it's important to
provide energy to cells.
OK.
All right.
Now, if we're going to make a
pathway where glucose oxidation
is coupled to making PEP
and 1,3-Bisphosphoglycerate,
it's obvious we need to add
phosphate to the system.
There's no phosphate
molecule on glucose.
Now already mentioned earlier--
and I just erased it--
that to trap glucose in
the cell, the first step
in glycolysis,
you add phosphate.
But that phosphate donor is ATP.
And so ATP being the phosphate
donor doesn't help us here.
If we're going to use
phosphate transfer here,
we need to have phosphate
added into the system
if this is going to work.
We can't have ATP as
our phosphate donor.
You also saw lots of
reactions from Professor Yaffe
that involved phosphate
transfer reactions.
But again, ATP-- or GTP
is the phosphate donor.
And so for this system to work,
we need a way to get inorganic
phosphate onto a carbohydrate
or we can't make things like PEP
or 1,3-Bisphosphoglycerate
that will allow ATP synthesis.
Now we already saw earlier that
additional phosphate to glucose
is not favored.
Remember, delta G0 prime
of phosphorylating glucose
was plus 3.3 kcals per mole.
And it turns out
that says equilibrium
lies to the wrong side,
so we can't net do that
without ATP or energy input.
And it turns out this is true
for other sugars as well.
And so you need energy input
to add phosphate to the sugars.
Plenty of energy input
from glucose oxidation,
but we need a reaction where
phosphate addition is coupled
to another reaction
that makes it favorable,
and we have to do this
without making ATP.
And again, it
illustrates, again,
the biological energy
is not just about ATP.
At a deeper level It's
something different.
And so to really discuss
this and understand it,
I need to introduce
two concepts that
are going to come up again over
and over again in this class
and across metabolism.
The first of these is a
very high-level bioenergetic
concept, although it's
really an energetic concept,
and it comes back to what
we already talked about.
So, we know burning
wood is favorable.
The CN H2O N plus oxygen
going to CO2 plus water.
That's burning wood,
lots of energy released.
Drew it up there for a
single-glucose molecule
and what the energy
release the delta G0
prime is for that reaction.
Now I want to point
out chemically
what is going on
in this reaction.
Chemically what is
happening for this
to occur is that
electrons from the carbon
are being moved
to the oxygen. You
are changing the oxidation
state of carbon and of oxygen
in order to carry
out this reaction.
Oxygen is a better electron
acceptor than carbon,
and so transferring
those electrons
from the carbon to the
oxygen is favorable.
That is, in essence, what is
going on in this very favorable
reaction to burn wood.
Let me illustrate that a
bit more explicitly here.
So the carbon-- most of the
carbons in carbohydrates
are alcohols.
So here, you can call
this our carbohydrate,
with the exception of the
ketone or the aldehyde
if it's a ketose or an aldose.
All the other carbons in
the sugar are alcohols.
All the other bonds there.
And so if we oxidize
that carbon--
that is, if we remove
electrons from the carbon,
how can we do that?
So this here generates
this H- hydride ion.
This is, in essence,
two electrons
that we are removing
from the carbon.
That gives us a ketone.
So if we oxidize the alcohol
and we remove two electrons,
we get the ketone.
We could oxidize
this ketone further.
That will give us
the carboxylic acid.
If we oxidize it even
further, now we get CO2.
So, moving in this
direction, this is oxidation.
Transferring electrons from
the carbon to the oxygen
to go in this oxidation
direction, that
is glucose oxidation
is what's happening
when we're burning wood.
It's what happens
when we burn glucose.
Energy is released.
This is largely what catabolism
is about in biological systems.
Now then reasons,
then, that if we're
going to move in the opposite
direction, so-called reduction,
that is going in this direction.
Reduction.
That's largely energy storage
or anabolism in metabolism.
We are storing energy
that we can burn later.
And of course, what's the
more extreme version of this?
Well, what if we add two more
electrons to the carbon going
in this direction?
Well, what do we end up with?
Well, now we end up with
the saturated carbon.
more reduced than the alcohol
is the fully saturated carbon.
You will see later that
this is what fat is.
You saw that in some of
the earlier lectures.
It's also what gasoline is.
What's gasoline?
It's fully saturated
hydrocarbons that we then
burn to CO2 and derive energy.
Just like burning wood, burning
gasoline all in one step,
oxidizing the gasoline
gives you energy.
There's more energy in gasoline.
You can release more
energy per weight
from gasoline, from
fully-saturated hydrocarbons
than you can from wood.
Same thing happening here.
What has more
calories in your food?
Everyone knows fat has more
calories per weight than sugar.
It's because the more
reduced our carbon is,
the more energy it stores, and
as we oxidize that carbon, that
is what releases the energy.
And so energy transduction
in biological systems--
and actually, in
non-biological systems,
as I just illustrated with
the wood and gasoline example,
but definitely in
biological systems,
is largely about oxidation
and reduction reactions,
and you are going to see this
coming up over and over again.
Now, based on what I just said,
the real magic, if you will,
of glycolysis can be further
refined to say that what
glycolysis does is it couples
the favorable oxidation
of carbon with reactions that
allow phosphate additions
and production of
intermediates, like PEP
and 1,3-Bisphosphoglycerate,
where synthesis of ATP is
favored despite the high
ATP-ADP ratio in cells.
If you think about
it, that process
then allows you to
keep that ATP-ADP ratio
in the range where
it can then be
useful for all the reasons we've
been talking about now for two
lectures.
Allows the cell to couple that
ATP-ADP ratio, that-- in ATP
hydrolysis to
otherwise carry out
otherwise unfavorable reactions.
OK.
So, based on that,
arguably the key,
or at least a very important
reaction in glycolysis,
is the oxidation step which
happens to add the phosphate
and also happens to make
1,3-Bisphosphoglycerate,
which we saw earlier can be
used to drive ATP synthesis.
And so that reaction
is the following.
So this molecule hopefully
looks familiar to you
from the carbohydrate lectures.
This is D-glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate.
I will abbreviate
it frequently is
G-3P for glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate,
but it's D-glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate.
Remember, it's a D,
sugar, because the OH
group is pointing to the
right as we drew it this way.
It's also an aldose because
it's a aldehyde sugar,
and it's phosphorylated
on the 3 position--
remember the way we
numbered sugars was starting
at the carbonyl--
1, 2, 3.
This is carbon-3,
phosphorylation on the 3
position.
Glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate.
OK.
So, this step generates
1,3-Bisphosphoglycerate.
Well, to do this,
there's actually
two things that happened here.
First we had to add
the phosphate to this.
It says two phosphates on
it. bisphosphoglycerate,
this has a single phosphate.
So inorganic phosphate
has to be added
to generate that molecule.
By the way, adding that
phosphate delta G0 prime
is positive plus
1.5 kcals per mole.
That means even
equilibrium, this reaction
would lie to the
left, of course,
because delta G0
prime is positive.
However, remember the next
step downstream of this
is the one shown over here
where we do ATP synthesis.
That step is very favorable.
So this is an example
where metabolism
has coupled a very favorable
step to a step that's
less favorable.
That can keep the 1,3-BPG levels
low and pull the entire system
forward, the metabolic trick we
discussed in the last lecture.
OK.
You'll note the other thing
that's happening here,
other than adding
that phosphate group,
is that we've changed this
aldehyde to a carboxylic acid.
That is an oxidation reaction.
Ketone to the acid is
an oxidation reaction.
I will illustrate over
here this so you can see
why it's an oxidation reaction.
So here's our aldehyde.
If we take electrons
from the carbon
and that generates this
hydride ion to electrons,
what are we left with?
Well, we're left with
this intermediate
that will never exist with a
positive charge on the carbon.
Water, which, of course, is
abundant in biological systems.
And then come--
OK.
And it basically
illustrates that as I
go from the aldehyde
to the acid, of course,
I make a proton
and a hydride ion,
but really, I have changed the
oxidation state of the carbon
from the ketone
to the acid state.
Two electrons are lost there,
is shown as that hydride ion.
OK.
So, what does that mean?
Well, that means that we
have to maintain that balance
in this reaction as well.
So water is going
to have to come in
and a proton will be produced.
But the key thing
is we also generate
two electrons, this hydride
ion that have to go somewhere.
Now, finding a place for
those two electrons to go
is what brings up the
second high-level concept
that I now need to spend
some time discussing.
And this second
high-level concept
that I need to introduce
is the role of cofactors,
and cofactors also
is effectively
the role of vitamins
and what role
that these things
play in metabolism.
Most vitamins are used to
support metabolic reactions,
and we're going to
learn all about what
many of the vitamins that you
guys are familiar with reading
the side of your
cereal box actually
do throughout the course.
Now cofactors, as I said,
often involve vitamins,
are molecules that provide
useful chemical groups that
facilitate the reaction
chemistries that
are needed in metabolism.
So they provide some
useful chemical groups
to facilitate some
of the chemistries
that we need to carry
out metabolic reactions.
They are, in general, in small
non-stoichiometric quantities
in order to carry
out this function.
What do I mean by that?
Meaning that you can imagine
that the cell will convert lots
of glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate
to 1,3-Bisphosphoglycerate,
but the enzyme, you don't need
one enzyme for every time you
convert that reaction.
The same enzyme can do it
over and over and over again.
Well, it turns out,
cofactors are much more
like enzymes in that respect.
They need to be
recycled in a way
that they can catalyze
the turnover of reaction
many, many, many
times, and it'll
be much clearer what
I mean by this when we
get into some of the details.
Now, the vitamin concept
comes from the fact
that often these cofactors
or parts of the cofactors
are not made by animals,
not made by humans.
If they're not
made by us, but we
need them to do our
metabolism, well now we
have to get them from the
diet, and this is really
the concept of vitamins.
These are small
things that we have
to get in quantities
from the diet,
and it turns out they're very
important to help us carry out
the metabolism we do.
As an aside, the
vitamin industry
is a very big business.
Lots of unfounded
claims out there.
I'm not going to get into--
that can get very political.
I'm just going to say that
just know that more is not
always better, and the
goal for this class
is really to understand
what some of these vitamins
actually do.
OK.
Now, the relevant cofactor for
the reaction that we're talking
about is a cofactor called
nicotinamide adenine
dinucleotide, which is always
abbreviated NAD or NAD+.
This stands for nicotinamide
adenine dinucleotide.
You see why we want to
abbreviate that NAD.
And basically what nicotinamide
adenine dinucleotide is is it's
a factor that can solve
our problem of where
to put these electrons in
this oxidation reaction.
That is, you can
accept two electrons
from a reaction
like this one here
and cycle to another form
of the cofactor called NADH.
All right.
What is nicotinamide
adenine dinucleotide?
Well first, let's draw
what it looks like.
OK.
Sorry it's squeeze
down here a little bit.
So this here is adenine.
This group up here
is nicotinamide.
So if you look at this,
this is a dinucleotide.
And so down here, this, of
course, is, from here down,
is AMP.
That phosphate is now over here.
This is a separate
nucleotide, where
rather than having
one of the AGCTU bases
that you're used to from RNA and
DNA, nicotinamide is the base.
And so it's this AMP
plus this nicotinamide
base is a monophosphate,
or a nicotinamide adenine
dinucleotide.
This, the nicotinamide
group, is derived
from a vitamin called niacin.
And so from the side
of your cereal box,
this is what niacin does.
It allows you to generate
the nicotinamide group that's
part of this cofactor,
nicotinamide adenine
dinucleotide.
Now, nicotinamide
adenine dinucleotide
is useful because of what that
nicotinamide group can do.
And so I'm not going to
draw out the whole molecule,
but I'll show you.
So NAD+, which is the oxidized
form of nicotinamide adenine
dinucleotide, is as
I drew it up there.
So this here would be
attached to the rest
of the dinucleotide.
So this is the oxidized form.
I can have-- here's my
hydride ion, which, remember,
is two electrons.
If I carry out that chemistry
to add those two electrons
to the nicotinamide
group, you now end up
with the reduced form
of nicotinamide adenine
dinucleotide NADH.
So the difference between
NAD+ and NADH, it's the H,
but it's really the two
electrons that were added
in adding that H. So it's
oxidized form and reduced form.
So remember, I want to stress
this again, at least in biology
we can't create
or destroy matter.
You can do that in
nuclear physics,
but we can't do that in biology.
And so that means that if we
do an electron transfer like we
did in this reaction where
we oxidized the aldehyde
in glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate to the acid
in 1,3-Bisphosphoglycerate,
those electrons have to be
accounted for.
And so if one
molecule is oxidized,
another one has to be reduced.
So redox reactions
always-- that is,
redox, oxidation-reduction
reactions,
always have to happen in pairs.
And so over there we have the
aldehyde in glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate is oxidized
to form the acid
in 1,3-Bisphosphoglycerate.
As part of that reaction,
we can couple it such
that the nicotinamide group,
which is oxidized in NAD,
can be reduced to the
nicotinamide group that
is found in NADH.
So that means we can
draw this in here,
is that having that cofactor
coupled to this reaction
now allows us to fix the redox
problem of this reaction.
Now this reaction
here is catalyzed
by an enzyme called glycerol
3-phosphate dehydrogenase.
I'll draw that
out in the second.
Often abbreviated GAPDH,
the loading control
in all of your western
blots, is the enzyme GAPDH,
glyceraldehyde
phosphate dehydrogenase.
That is the enzyme that
carries out that reaction.
Now notice, the name fits.
It's a dehydrogenase,
it's removing a hydrogen,
removing two electrons
as a hydride ion,
but it's really--
what's important here
is the electrons moving,
not the hydrogen itself.
So in that way it's a
little bit misleading.
And you will see that in
general, dehydrogenases
are classes of
enzymes that catalyze
oxidation-reduction
reactions, and as a result,
often involve
NAD/NADH as cofactors
because they facilitate those
electron transfer reactions.
OK.
So now we're able
to describe how
GAPDH works in great detail.
And so the chemistry of
GAPDH works as follows.
And so in the active
site of GAPDH,
there's a cystine residue.
That cystine residue
has a sulfur shown here.
Also bound near the active
site is in NAD molecule
to catalyze the reaction shown.
That NAD has to be in the
oxidized state, so it's NAD+.
And so glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate binds
in the active site.
There's glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate.
By the way, I will show you how
many reactions in metabolism
work chemically.
Obviously we don't have time in
this class, an overview class
to go into all the great
chemical details of what's
going on and exactly
how everything works,
but I'll at least
try to give you
a flavor of some of
the chemistry that
happens throughout the course.
All right.
So once you have, then--
OK.
So now you have this
intermediate bound
into the enzyme active site.
You can now carry out the
oxidation of that carbon.
So these are two electrons
being removed as a hydride ion.
They can be transferred
to NAD in the active site.
That generates NADH
by the exact chemistry
that I just showed you.
OK.
That NADH now needs
to be exchanged out
or the enzyme will not
be able to catalyze
the next series of reactions,
and that NADH will then
go somewhere else,
and of course,
has to be cycled back to
NAD, but that doesn't happen
in this reaction, per se.
OK.
Next, this here, you'll
notice, is that by the way
this chemistry worked, we
formed this thioester bond
in the active site.
This is another thing that you
will see over and over again
in metabolism.
This sulfur in the thioester
bond is a good leaving group,
and so it's really setting up
a situation that will now help
with the phosphate addition.
So here, I'll draw out
inorganic phosphate.
And that, of course, will give
us the identical enzyme active
site that we started with
plus 1,3-Bisphosphoglycerate.
And that 1,3-Bisphosphoglycerate
can now be coupled to ATP
synthesis to make
3-phosphoglycerate.
And so you can see, in essence,
what this reaction has done is
that it has coupled oxidation
of the aldehyde to the acid,
the aldehyde in
3-phosphate to the acid
in 1,3-Bisphosphoglycerate,
which can then do
phosphorylation of
ADP to make ATP.
So in essence, this is
oxidative phosphorylation.
Now I realize in high
school or in other classes,
oxidative phosphorylation means
something different to you,
and of course, we will
discuss the process that
is called oxidative
phosphorylation in great detail
later in this course.
But I want to point out that
the chemistry that's actually
happening here in glycolysis is
also oxidative phosphorylation.
It's basically how you coupled
this favorable carbon oxidation
that's occurring
at this GAPDH step
in a way that allows
you to synthesize ATP
at a high ATP-ADP ratio, which
in the end will allow cells
to do otherwise
unfavorable things.
OK.
Now we're ready to discuss these
reactions, the GAPDH reaction,
the pyruvate kinase reaction,
the phosphoglycerate kinase
reaction, and how they
fit into glycolysis
as a metabolic pathway in a
way that allows cells to use
glucose metabolism-- that
is, the breakdown of glucose,
the burning of glucose
as a way to get energy.
And that pathway is, of course,
glycolysis or glucose lysis
that we mentioned earlier.
Glycolysis is a very ancient
and ubiquitous pathway.
It's used by essentially
all life on Earth
and probably has been for at
least 2 to 3 billion years.
Glycolysis, I guess,
as a pathway was,
quote-unquote, "discovered"
mid-19th century
by Louis Pasteur,
and Louis Pasteur,
of course, described
life, microorganisms
as being responsible for
the process of fermentation.
That is, conversion of glucose
into alcohol, something
many college students are
interested in, as well
as other organic acids.
And of course, fermentation
to make alcohol
or to store other
types of organic acids
has been used in
food preservation
for centuries, which is really
why Pasteur's discoveries were
so impactful at the time.
Now even though Pasteur
discovered this,
he didn't really understand
chemically how it worked,
and it actually took
decades to figure that out.
And when it was finally
figured out and described
as the pathway
called glycolysis,
this was done by two chemists,
two chemists in Germany, Embden
and Meyerhof.
And basically what they
did is they pieced together
several enzymatic or
chemical activities that
have been purified from cell
lysates mostly from yeast
and used those to build
a pathway that described
chemically how you
could start with glucose
and chemically break down that
glucose in a way that made
sense in this
fermentation pathway,
and that is why glycolysis
is sometimes called
the Embden-Meyerhof pathway.
Now, glycolysis
does not completely
convert glucose to CO2.
Instead, what glycolysis
does is it converts glucose--
so I will draw here
in the pyranose form.
It converts glucose
by a number of steps
into two molecules of the
organic acid pyruvate, which,
of course, was the product of
that pyruvate kinase reaction
that we showed earlier.
Note that the fermentation
that Louis Pasteur described
was further metabolism of that
pyruvate into something else.
In the case of yeast, it was
ethanol or ethyl alcohol,
or something else.
The fermentative
product in mammals
is this organic acid lactate.
And what we will
see next time is
that this fermentation
of pyruvate
into one of these
other molecules
ends up being an alternative
to the further oxidation
of pyruvate to CO2
which requires oxygen,
and the reason oxidizing
pyruvate to CO2
requires oxygen is
because ultimately we
have to regenerate that NADH
we made in glycolysis to allow
that cofactor to cycle and
glycolysis to keep moving.
Fermentation gives
us an alternative way
to do this, which we'll
discuss in great detail
in the next lecture.
But first I want to
focus on glycolysis
and what we can describe
next time as really how
we can build a pathway to
turn glucose into pyruvate.
This glycolysis, this
Embden-Meyerhof pathway,
and some of the
details of that pathway
are shown here on this slide.
And this is where we'll
start off the next lecture,
discussing how each of these
steps in glycolysis function
in a way that allow a pathway
to generate phosphoenolpyruvate,
1,3-Bisphosphoglycerate,
incorporate this GAPDH
reaction, and do so in a way
that's overall energetically
favorable to allow the cell
to couple this oxidation
of glucose to keeping ATP-ADP
ratio in the right range
to support other unfavorable
functions in the cell.
OK, thanks.